Hey, I'm John Green, and this WILL be Crash
Course Literature, but not for two weeks,
because I have to give you your reading list,
so you can like, you know, read the things
that we're going to talk about!
I enjoyed spinning, so I'm going to do that
again.
Your first book?
The Odyssey by Homer.
No, Stan, come on.
Homer.
Yes, the one with all of the blood and misogyny.
And then we've got Oedipus, by Sophocles,
everybody's favorite play about patricide
and incest.
Speaking of murder, third we have Hamlet,
by William Shakespeare That was one too many
spins and I don't feel so good.
Fourth on your reading list, Mary Shelley's
Frankenstein, my all-time favorite novel about
industrialization.
Then we'll be reading Charlotte Brontë's
brilliant and tubercular masterpiece Jane
Eyre.
Sixth, we'll be reading Chinua Achebe's Things
Fall Apart.
Then we have To Kill a Mockingbird by Harper
Lee, the Boo Radley of American literature.
Then comes the World War II novel Slaughterhouse
Five by Kurt Vonnegut.
And lastly, we'll be reading one of my favorite
American novels, Beloved by Toni Morrison.
You can find links to get all of these books,
many of which are free, in the video info
below.
And we'll probably also be reading some poetry,
but I don't know what yet.
Anyway, thank you for watching, get to reading,
and we say in my hometown, do too many spins
and you will eventually vomit.
[Stan talks in background]
John: Okay, okay.
He barely murders anyone in that play, really.
He doesn't have the courage.
Stan: ...straight-out, he kills Polonius straight-out.
John: Doesn't he kill Polonius through a,
uh... through a curtain by accident?
Stan: He's stabbing someone.
I mean...
John: He thinks he's stabbing his dad.
Stan: Right.
His stepdad.
John: Yeah, he kills the wrong dude.
Stan: That's... the murder.
John: Stan and I are fighting about whether
Hamlet really murders anybody in Hamlet.
Stan: ...in a month or so.
John: We should put that in... at the end
of the video.
Stan: Yeah, yeah.
John: The video should end with us doing this
right now.
Stan: Okay.
John: This should be the end.